foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 10 our top story
holding on in a sea of supports the
parents of these student victims of the
Nottingham attacks
[Music]
um
look after your friends
and look after people around you
Grace Somali come up Barnaby Webber and
school caretaker Ian Coates were killed
as police work flat out to establish
what happened
the suspect thoughts to be seen here
trying to break into a hostel after the
students had already been stabbed
also tonight risking all to reach Europe
we report from Greece as this migrant
boat capsizes killing at least 79.
pots dry and dangerous we see the
firefighters trying to put out wildfires
with much of the country now at high
risk
thank you
[Applause]
there are those who applaud and those
who detest the eulogy to Italy's
controversial former leader Silvio
Berlusconi laid to rest
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening it was a journey no parent
would ever want to make traveling to
their child's University not to collect
them for the summer but to join a vigil
to remember them Barnaby Weber and Grace
Somali Kumar had loved being at
Nottingham their parents said the family
of the third victim Ian Coates who was
just four months from retirement said he
was everyone's friend and always willing
to help in a moment we'll see CCTV which
appears to show the suspect trying to
force his way into a residential home
but first our national correspondents
Tom Parmenter reports
at the heart of this vast emotional
Gathering there were families who are in
all of their thoughts
the mothers of Barnaby and Grace met
here in the place where their children
learned and lived
it was a day to hold each other tight
the two students were both 19 years old
their lives filled with energy and
opportunities
but everything stopped early on Tuesday
morning when they were stabbed to death
as they made their way home after a
night out in Nottingham
their fathers wanted to speak to the
thousands standing silently on campus
I've lost my baby boy
and I can't
even comprehend how I'm going to do and
deal with it myself and Emma and
Charlene this family and friends
well I know Martin would be super
touched by everyone that's here
and he he loved it he loved it here he
couldn't wait to come back the love that
we have out here are just
wish we had it everywhere
so
thank you
look after each other
it's the big thing
is that
look after your friends
and look after people around you
relatives of the third victim of the
attacks were also here at the vigil Ian
Coates was a school caretaker a devoted
Grandad who was soon due to retire
another innocent victim
they laid hundreds of single stems
family
teammates
friends
and University staff
what should have been one of the biggest
celebrations the student body has turned
into one of our darkest days
Barney and grace are a Monumental loss
they were both First Years with
ambitions potential and dreams
what was taken from us yesterday will
never be given back and the shockwaves
echo through our student Community Grace
had represented England at hockey for
the under 16 and under 18 age groups she
was a huge talent and she was a medical
student who volunteered to give people
vaccines during the pandemic
Barnaby from Taunton in Somerset was
also excelling at Sports and his history
studies
his university cricket team just one of
the many places where he felt right at
home just a great blow because it threw
himself into everything every social
here is there every training session
every match supporting playing he's
always there it was amazing grace was
incredibly well known as well yes she
was she was incredibly well known she
was um I have many mutual friends in the
hockey club and around and no one can
speak highly enough of her as well
there is just no explanation yet as to
why all this has happened why these
families have been thrust into such
unbearable pain but they had enormous
support here today and they will need to
draw on that in the days ahead
the families have traveled many hours to
be here but right now in this shared
moment of grief
he didn't want to be anywhere else
Tom Parmenter Sky News Nottingham
well the Home Secretary says today that
police are keeping an open mind over the
attacks and they're still working with
anti-terror police CCTV appears to show
the suspect after Barnaby Weber and
Grace O'Malley Kumar was stabbed as our
crime correspondent Martin brunt our
reports
this was the suspect trying to break
into a charity hostel and being shoved
away an hour earlier two students had
been stabbed to death minutes later a
third victim had also been stabbed his
van stolen and three pedestrians mowed
down a charity trustee said residents
had a lucky Escape an event like this
can definitely turn people's feelings up
especially when they're already kind of
vulnerable for people that are healthier
so yeah and and it was that was anyone
harmed or anything uh there was no one
out of that from our residents I can
confirm that quite shaken uh yes
emotionally people
the suspect of 31 year old man was still
being questioned as the investigation
continued here police finishing a search
of what's thought to be the suspect's
former home in a newly released more
detailed timeline police said they were
called at four minutes past four on
Tuesday morning they found students
Barnaby Weber and Grace O'Malley
unresponsive in ilkeston Road the man
matching the suspect's description was
then seen trying to get into the hostel
in mappily Road
the suspect is then thought to have
stabbed Ian Coates on magdala road and
stolen his van
within minutes the van was used to run
down three people on Milton Street a man
is critical in hospital the other two
have minor injuries
soon after police say the suspect
abandoned the van and confronted
officers with a knife he was tasered and
arrested
they are currently keeping an open mind
as to the motives Behind these attacks
but I can confirm Nottinghamshire police
are being assisted in their inquiries by
counter-terror police though this does
not mean that it is currently being
treated as a terrorist attack
on the road where the student died the
crime scene investigation was over as
police began a cleanup
we now know that Grace ran from her
attacker into the front garden of this
house and tried to get help but nobody
was home that night and Grace died on
the doorstep the woman who lives here
told us she was heartbroken maybe she
said we could have saved her
police have until Saturday morning to
question their suspect before they must
charge or release him Martin brunt Sky
News Nottingham
now there are fears tonight of a major
tragedy in the Mediterranean and for a
fishing boat packed with migrants
capsized at least 79 people are known to
have died but many many more are missing
or Greek authorities say the sinking
happened early this morning about 46
miles Southwest of Greece the survivors
and the recovered bodies have been taken
by ship to the port of Kalamata well as
the bunkel is in southern Greece first
night and joins us now Alistair
well we believe that this ship left the
Libyan Port of to Brook now on Tuesday
it was approached by a number of vessels
asking whether it needed any help or
assistance they declined and said that
they were on route to Italy and that is
where they wanted to get to and then at
around 2 A.M on Wednesday morning the
early hours of this morning it reported
engine failure a Greek Coast Guard
vessel nearby said it swerved to the
right to the left and then sharply again
to the right before it capsized throwing
people overboard and almost certainly
dragging others down with it
the survivors that were found were
winched to safety in a massive rescue
operation in the middle of the
Mediterranean Sea the Dead were from
Egypt Syria Palestine and Pakistan
they'd gone to Libya first and then
tried to make it into Europe
we collected 104 people that are here at
the harbor at Kalamata in safe places
doctors and nurses have come from the
hospital to examine the immigrants 21 of
them were taken to hospital for
intensive care plus four more that from
the first moment were taken to the
hospital by helicopter because they were
more heavily injured the rescues have
been taken to Mainland Greece they are
being looked after by Aid agencies the
injured have been taken to hospital some
are suffering from hypothermia
we are here offering first aid and
psychological support to those people
who have suffered a very heavy blow both
physical and mental uh
distressed who wouldn't be distressed
after a shipwreck we hope more survivors
will be found from this shipwreck
it's not known how many were on board
but judging by pictures there could have
been hundreds many of them below deck
and out of sight
Greek Coast Guard ships a Navy frigate
helicopters and a military plane are all
searching the area for more survivors
and possibly more bodies
the search will continue overnight but
the ship sank in one of the deepest
parts of the Mediterranean making any
recovery that much harder
the United Nations says that the route
between North Africa and Italy is the
most dangerous migrant Crossing in the
world
17 000 people have died over the past
decade
Sky News recently witnessed hundreds
being rescued trying to cross into
Europe
the weather is good now the Seas
generally calmer and so Smugglers are
taking advantage and more people are
trying to make the crossing whilst they
can
this is already a major disaster and the
death toll is likely to rise further
well the rescue operation is continuing
tonight that is unusual they'll normally
stop at sundown but they know that there
are potentially hundreds of people
either to recover or lie alive or
perhaps more bodies in the sea I've
covered many of these disasters too many
quite frankly and often you find that
people on board are unable to swim or
there are just too few life jackets to
go around so I think the expectation is
that the death toll could rise and could
rise quite considerably particularly
when you consider those photographs you
saw in my report of just how many people
were crammed onto that vessel and the
interim Greek government has announced a
three-day period of morning again that
is unusual for a migrant disaster but
again I think it probably shows the
scale of what has happened and the
expectation of how much worse it could
be
Alistar for now thank you
now the report into whether Boris
Johnson misled Parliament over parties
in number 10 will be released tomorrow
morning but tonight the former prime
minister's war against the committee
seems to have gone into overdrive he's
called for one of its members the brexit
supporting conservative Grande sir
Bernard Jenkin to resign our Deputy
political editor Sam coaches in
Westminster for us tonight good evening
samsa Boris Johnson's remaining the
story again for another day at least
that's right tonight the former prime
minister has launched an extra set
against the Tory Committee Member of the
Privileges committee sir Bernard Jenkin
which the Edo Forks website has accused
of attending a lockdown breaking party
himself in December 2020 now Boris
Johnson calls this monstrous hypocrisy
and says that Bernard Jenkins really
should have stood down at the start of
this inquiry that's the route of the
evening but to what end because tomorrow
morning at 9 00 a.m the Privileges
committee will release a 30 000 word
report into whether or not Boris Johnson
deliberately misled Parliament and we
already know much of what's going to
come tomorrow we know that it will found
that he did do that because Boris
Johnson has told us as such nor are
there any really sanctions that MPS can
Levy against Boris Johnson because he
has already stood down as an MP why
tomorrow really matters is because it
will show us where the conservative
party is are there Defenders of Boris
Johnson in the chamber or do they sit on
their hands and let the report go
through without comment does Boris
Johnson remain an itch that present and
future Tory MPS feel the need to scratch
when times get tough and get a sense of
whether that's the case tomorrow we
certainly will Sam for now thank you
well there is a big difference between a
pay demand of 35 percent and a payoffer
of 5 and there's no sign of it being
bridged as Junior doctors says their
latest three-day strike patients are as
ever bearing the brand and our health
correspondent Ashish Joshi has spoken to
one of them
you okay
careful what
what okay Hillary is in absolute agony
one Stones she's been waiting for a hip
replacement since the start of the
pandemic and was finally due to have won
two days ago but it was canceled because
of the doctor's strike lovely you're
obviously in agony how difficult is it
for you to manage day to day I'm
constantly in pain I can't sleep at
night so I have to have a chair next to
the bed I can't walk to the pillar box
to post a letter and I can't go shopping
I can't meet friends for lunch I can't
do my job I'm in pain
brings you frustration
the latest three-day strike by Junior
doctors will bring huge disruption to
NHS Services they insist this action is
needed to make the government listen to
their demands 35
um it would be to restore our pay back
to Net Zero if it's too much to ask for
it's too much for us to lose doctors
have seen a huge paper over the last 15
years we're not asking for all that
money back in one go we're being very
reasonable saying that we're willing to
work with the government in creative
ways to get back to Net Zero the
government though says the doctors are
asking for too much it claims it is
prepared to negotiate but only if they
call off their strikes first we moved in
terms of the government's position in
line with the offer that was accepted by
the NHS staff Council and by trade
unions representing a number of other
health workers and made an offer in line
with that but unfortunately the junior
doctors have refused to move from their
demand for 35 percent uh they're still
insisting on an increase of 35
industrial action this year has already
forced the cancellation of half a
million appointments but it's not just
operations these strikes put pressure on
every part of the hospital we've been
seeing a heat increase in activity
unprecedented actually over the last few
days and with the industrial action
that's happening this week as well we're
going to have a High attendance figures
which will lead to longer weights
Hillary has been told she will have her
operation in July but she's afraid it
might take longer unless this bitter
dispute is resolved oh she's Josh is Sky
News in Essex
now one of the factors putting pressure
on the NHS this week is the prolonged
hot spell but it's not only the only
emergency service that's on alert the
risk of wildfires across much of Britain
is high according to the Met Office and
our science correspondent Thomas Moore
saw how firefighters attacking one in
South Wales today
it's still early summer but already the
wildfires are burning
this is rigos mountain in South Wales
the Flames are proving so hard to
extinguish they're having to Fight Fire
With Fire
specialist teams burn off the vegetation
to create a fire break a tactic more
common in the far hot spots of
California now needed in the UK as the
climate changes
because of the weather conditions it
doesn't matter how much water we put in
this fire it will dry out and it will
reignite so our only method here is to
go along control burning according to
the Met Office much of England and parts
of Wales are now at very high risk of
wildfires
while in Scotland firefighters continue
to battle a fire near Inverness North
and South the Heat Wave and lack of rain
have dried out the landscape
it is very early in the summer and last
year when we had to fight in London he
went to I believe extreme but that was a
lot later in the year how this year will
build now is quite worrying
the wildfire in Wellington East London
which destroyed several houses is
driving the Tactical rethink drought
provides fires with so much fuel they
spread fast and they're more intense
this shows how difficult it is to
extinguish wildfires of this size now in
the UK the vegetation much of it has
gone but there's enough left for the
flame still to burn although the
firefighters have now moved on following
the fire front
they'll come back and deal with these
later
the Met Office predicts UK Summers will
get hotter and drier in the decades
ahead and firefighters are braced for
what's to come
Thomas More Sky News in South Wales
now there is little sign of relief in
sight for millions of mortgage holders
with interest rates predicted to keep on
Rising and that could also impact
economic growth the UK grew a little
richer in April with GDP up 0.2
percenter economics and data editor Ed
Conway looks at what happens next
so we just got the latest data on the UK
economy the state of the economy GDP
here it is this is showing you the big
picture of gross domestic product the
size of the economy it's the level here
you can see the pandemic there that big
fall and the latest numbers show it's
0.2 growth uh in April but the thing I
want you to focus on is basically that
line we're kind of back at pre-pandemic
levels just about but essentially we're
flatlining and most economists think
it's going to carry on that way not
necessarily shrinking but if there is
even a slight deviation we could well be
in recession and the reason that matters
is we'll look at what's happening in the
mortgage market right now now these are
the average rates that people are paying
if you're refixing your mortgage 5.54
this chart goes all the way back to the
1960s you can see there a bit higher for
two year break mortgages and it doesn't
look like it's very high does it that
line over there but higher since 2008
but here's the thing you've got to
adjust for the fact these are just the
headline mortgage rates just for the
fact that you have higher mortgages
right now people are more indebted they
have lower incomes in comparison with
their mortgages a just for all of that
and it's a very different picture you
get a very different line an effective
rate really showing the burden that
people are facing going all the way back
to the 1960s and have a look where we
are right now is actually the highest
since 1991 and remember 1991 official
rates were up at 13 that precipitated a
housing crash a recession where we're
kind of getting up towards those levels
right now and we might get there we
might even exceed it why we'll have a
look at what's happened to interest rate
expectations so this is a future
interest rate expectations for the bank
of England they've gone up an awful lot
because inflation has been a lot higher
than expects a lot higher than the bank
expected by the way they've just
announced they're going to do an
external review of their inflation
forecasting in the face of criticism
this is what was expected only last
month so rates were gonna Peak around
4.75 in the next few years just look at
how that's changed now the expectation
is they're going up to 5.75 so closing
in on six percent by the end of the year
the turn of next year that is really
high and that's yet to feed through to
those mortgage charts I showed you a
moment ago so things could get really
tough for you particularly if you have a
mortgage
now unlike in the UK in America there
was a pause in interest rate Rises this
evening the U.S federal reserve has kept
its key rate unchanged to end a run of
10 consecutive jumps the rate remains
between 5 and 5.25 their highest level
since 2007 but inflation in the US has
dropped to four percent less than half
the current level in the UK
the boss of ITV has admitted she is
deeply disappointed by allegations of a
toxic culture this morning following the
departure of Phillip Schofield named
Carolyn McCall and the ITV managing
director Kevin ligo faced questions from
MPS on the culture media and Sports
Select Committee but denied schofield's
affair with a younger male colleague was
an Open Secret at the broadcaster
the king and queen have hosted a
reception at Buckingham Palace to Mark
the 75th anniversary of the arrival in
the UK of the Empire wind Rush the ship
that brought the first of hundreds of
thousands of Caribbean migrants to help
rebuild Britain after the second world
war to Mark the occasion their Majesty's
unveiled 10 portraits of people who
arrived on those early voyagers
and you can learn more about the
Windrush generation in a special Sky
documentary marking the anniversary
Windrush and us will air on Sky
documentaries on Tuesday at 8 and on Sky
News next Wednesday at 8pm
now it was an unusual sentiment to hear
at a funeral an admission that there
were those who applauded the man at the
center of it and those who detested him
but that was the message as Italy's
former prime minister Silvio Berlusconi
was laid to rest our International
correspondent Alex Rossi reports now
from Milan
relax they turned out in their thousands
to say goodbye to a man who was never
far from Scandal
as the cop in made its way into the
cathedral there was Applause
and in his speech the Archbishop of
Milan paid tribute to Silvio
berlusconi's passion for life
at this moment of leave taking in prayer
what can we say of Sylvia bellusconi
that he was a man with a yearning for
life and love and a desire for joy
outside on huge screens his supporters
watched the service
for them this was a chance to celebrate
a leader who dominated politics and
public life for decades
it was a great politician but rusconi
was everything it's someone that really
gave a lot to Italy and I am I'm really
proud
with his permitanned smile Berlusconi
was for the world the face for many
years of Italian politics
he was a full-time prime minister but
controversy was never far away
Silvio Berlusconi was a polarizing and
divisive figure as prime minister he was
embroiled in numerous legal cases many
people thought he bought shame upon the
country but in death he has been
elevated now it appears a towering
figure of the Italian establishments
honored with a national day of mourning
an estate funeral
[Applause]
and even in death he is causing Discord
many Italians asking why such a
notorious man should be treated with
such reverence
he's a person that's in order to make
money and Achieve success ignored rights
people happiness and our future
what is not in question is that for
better or worse Sylvia Berlusconi was
without doubt one of Italy's most
influential politicians
his legacy is likely to be debated for
years to come
Alex Rossi Sky News Milan
well that was Sky News is 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
papers in the Press preview including
this on the front page of the Daily Mail
on the Nottingham attacks which shows
what it calls two fathers lost in grief
well tonight we're joined by the
associate editor of the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire and the deputy comment
editor of the telegraph animal day
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
you're watching at Sky News in just a
moment the Press previewer first look at
what is on the front pages as they
arrive but first our top stories the
families of two University students
killed in an attack in Nottingham have
attended a visual on campus
at least 79 people have died and more
are missing is a fishing boat carrying
migrants capsizes off the coast of
Southern Greece
Boris Johnson has demanded that an MP
who sits on the Parliamentary privileges
committee should quit over his own
lockdown Behavior as the committee
prepares to publish its report into the
former prime minister tomorrow morning
[Music]
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making headlines with the
associate editor of the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire and the deputy comment
editor at the telegraph Annabelle Denham
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight let's see what is on
some of those front pages and we'll
start with the front page of the Metro
which leads with the visual held for the
two students killed in Nottingham
thousands turned up to support The
Grieving families of Grace so malikumar
and Barnaby Weber
a similar headlined for the Daily
Express which describes the mood of the
vigil as one of numb and comprehending
grief
The Daily Mail focuses on the emotional
speeches made by both the victim's
fathers
the times picks out a quote from Grace's
father where he encouraged mourners to
look after each other and love everyone
the guardian reports on a groundbreaking
scientific Advance where scientists have
sidestepped the need for eggs and sperm
by creating a synthetic embryo using
stem cells
The Daily Telegraph reports on Boris
Johnson calling for saberna Jenkin to be
removed from the Privileges committee
over his alleged lockdown rule breaking
that's an image from Silvio berlusconi's
funeral on the front of the financial
times which also says there's pressure
on the Prime Minister over increasing
mortgage rates
and mortgages on the front of the I2
which says the tour is risk losing the
support of homeowners
and there's an AI warning from Elon Musk
on the front of the Daily Star
and a reminder by scanning the QR codes
you see on screen during the program you
can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch along
with us all right well but tonight we're
joined by Kevin McGuire and Annabelle
denim there they are in the big screen
good evening to you both Kevin Annabelle
great to have you with us and um we'll
start with the front page of the Metro
Kevin
um and uh as we said a number of papers
tomorrow covering that vigil in
Nottingham of these families grief
um there for everyone to see
no absolutely incredibly moving scenes
the matter have gone for the headline
United in love that's the the love of uh
you know their children to grieving
families and the father spoke uh so
movingly as did others and it's almost
impossible the only people who will
really know how they feel are those
who've suffered something similar uh
because it's beyond the comprehension of
most of us to to lose a child in such a
violent uh uh horrific way but it's a
how do those families cope uh how does
the students friends family uh you know
and also the those the friends and
family have uh have been 65 a school
caretaker who was uh was also murdered
in his van taken how do they cope and
that's that's the big question but uh
you know people are incredibly resilient
but listening to the father's uh you
know speak uh in a Barnaby's say he
doesn't know how it happened doesn't
know how he'll deal with it and Grace's
dad uh pictured their uh
look after each other it's it's just
kind of it's kind of really shocking
that it that it happened but it's now
how do we use you know as people respond
and deal with it yeah uh let's look at
the front of the of the mail if we can
now
um Annabelle uh as we talk about those
two fathers who
just showed Incredible strength to be
able to talk just a day after losing
their their children uh as Kevin said it
was it was so emotional so touching um
and really painful to kind of hear the
raw emotion that these guys are going
through
absolutely you know it's just it's just
awful and I think everyone's thoughts
are with those grief-stricken families
like Kevin says it's simply Beyond uh
every parent's worst nightmare it's it's
impossible to imagine and I think that
this trauma will be felt so widely
thousands of students attending that
vigil and like you say I think so
staggered really at the courage and
composure of those two fathers so soon
after this very violent uh attack and I
think you know I was really struck by
how this was happening to kids at
University this is often the first time
that people are away from their families
and indeed for the first time that
parents are sending their children away
and you know this this is simply the
absolute last thing that you would
expect to have happen and now you know
as time passes I think people are going
to want explanations they're going to
want answers we cannot understand we
cannot fathom why this happened
um we're only beginning to learn details
about the murder suspect and you know I
think we simply want to know what it was
that led to this absolutely heinous act
uh and Kevin do you think there are
going to be those questions to be asked
about
um the person who's responsible of
course there is someone in custody at
the moment arrested on suspicion of
murder
um
to try and find out exactly what's
transpired that men that a person like
this
um was able to carry out this kind of
act
yeah there has to be person in in
custody the police say they're not
looking for anybody else uh and you've
got to understand we've got to
understand why
why whoever did this I know there was a
legal process here why who did this did
it and you know where their
opportunities to stop them doing it that
was somehow missed uh I'm I don't intend
to you know or mean to blame anybody on
that but you know maybe maybe lessons
can be learned because it is just uh
absolutely appalling to how somebody
could murder three people two students a
mountain 65 still working uh he uses van
to run over three other people one of uh
whom is critically injured is just it's
just terrible it is you know it is
beyond beyond the comprehension of most
of us we have to get our heads around it
understand why why it happened and how
it might uh I say might have been uh
prevented all those questions have to be
asked yeah they do perhaps lessons to be
learned
the number of families Shattered by what
happened in Nottingham yesterday all
right let's move on to some of the
politics they're on the front pages now
and animal let's start off with you the
front page of the eye here
um there's the headline Tori is losing
support from home owners as hunt backs
new rate hike talk us through the
reporting here
sure so this is a new polling for uh the
eye it's suggesting that homeowners are
turning away from the conservatives I
don't think this is all together it's
surprising let's not forget the one
where she's senac came into number 10
the impression that he gave was one of a
quiet competence that he and Jeremy Hunt
would be very safe fans on the tiller
and now it looks very much like they
have lost control of the economy what we
are seeing are is Banks um freezing off
some of their offers
um perhaps raising mortgage rates in
response to the expectation that there
will be interest rates increases and why
we get why are those expectations
changing well it's off the back of this
very sticky inflation that we've seen
despite Rishi sunak pledging that
inflation would be halved by the end of
the year it is remaining stubbornly high
and earlier this week we had ons labor
market now data that found that wage
growth has gone up by seven percent now
this is still a reduction in real terms
but it's nonetheless and absolutely
massive number and it renews fears that
we now find ourselves in some kind of
wage price spiral where prices on the
shelves are going up so people are then
going to be demanding pay pay raises in
order to fund it which in turn is going
to lead to companies needing to increase
their prices uh in order to meet those
paid demands and you can see how you get
into that spiral which Jeremy Hunt which
Rishi sunak which Andrew Bailey are all
absolutely terrified of and you know as
the eye is pointing out this is simply
something that the Tories cannot ignore
they are going to pay for this at the
next general election unless they can
find a way to grow the economy to cut
taxes
um you know and to to bring down
inflation it's not exactly within Jeremy
hunt I'm actually seeing that's gift
it's very much the responsibility of the
monetary policy committee at the bank of
England but nonetheless it looks like
um the most senior members of our
government are throwing their weight
behind the decisions that the NPC will
be making yeah and I'm glad you
mentioned that wage price spiral Kevin
because that is what has always been
Finn what's been talked about but Kevin
as you know and I saw you shaking ahead
at some of that there is another way of
doing this and if we look at what's
happened in the states right now they've
paused the rate Rises they've managed to
get inflation under control so there are
other factors and the comparisons don't
often work I mean
Annabelle said you know that was a
promise by Rishi sunat to bring
inflation down its remaining sticky it's
maybe going up and rates are rising as
well
no no absolutely the next uh next week
uh expected to go up again with uh
Jeremy Hunt back in it and the the Ft uh
rather similarly to to the eye I pointed
out sunak's gonna feel the hit on this
because they are rapid mortgage risers
dominating prime minister's questions uh
uh Kia storm are basically saying you
know sunax been distracted all this
nonsense with uh Johnson and honors but
they hsbc's put up uh cost of borrowing
twice a week it's worth remembering that
in December 2021 as recently as then it
interesting is for 0.1 percent the base
rate it's our 4.5 and it's going to go
higher that's an extra extraordinary
rise and it's quite right that inflation
eats into the value of you your wages
wages are chasing inflation inflation is
not too wages aren't creating the
inflation it's wages are chasing
inflation but it damages your living
standards High inflation but so yeah
mortgage interest rates as they take uh
take your spending power away so it's
it's kind of people are under are under
assault from two directions when you've
got inflation of what you buy is going
up in price and then your your mortgages
your car loans your credit cards they're
going up too yeah and I don't know
you're kind of touching it a little bit
in your answer there there's all the
criticism coming from some of the
conservative party towards the um Bank
of England monetary policy committee but
I mean my thought on this is as rates
keep going up and we're going to start
seeing other parts of the political
divide perhaps questioning the way that
the bank of England have been raising
rates there was a question that perhaps
they should have got a hold of this
earlier and didn't act quickly enough
and those criticisms sort of are
lingering aren't they now
yes in fact I think the government was
quite slow uh to criticize the bank of
England for having extremely loose
monetary policy uh for far too long and
you know the bank of England has had a
bit of a Communications disaster uh ever
since it allowed this massive increase
in the broad supply of money during the
coronavirus uh pandemic Andrew Bailey
has been very quick to blame workers or
particularly older workers who've
decided to retire and he's criticized
those who've asked for pay Rises which I
think is frankly immoral people should
go to their employer and try and get the
best pay that they possibly can he
criticized some companies for their
pricing structures and I think it's
really time that the bank of England
took responsibility it was during in a
very difficult position during the
pandemic it was under immense pressure
to print money so that the government
could fund support packages such as a 70
billion pound furlough scheme but that
doesn't explain why it was so slow to
wake up to the inflationary threat and
to suggest for a really long time that
it was transitory I think we all know
now uh who we are in June 2023 that
inflation is not transitory it's very
damaging for the bank of England what it
needs more than anything else is to
restore credibility only then well
expectations of interest rates Rises
come down once people have realized or
at least expect that the bank of England
will get conflation under control but
until that point you know we are going
to see Banks to making these sorts of
moves increasing uh mortgage rates
perhaps pulling deals off the market and
for Richie sooner like the front of the
financial times says this is extremely
awkward let's not forget that it was
fears about a mortgage time bomb that
contributed to the ousting of Liz truss
and now the cost of government borrowing
is higher than it was after trust's mini
budget so the question will be does
Rishi seen that face similar risks I
think it's unlikely but and he is in a
very uncomfortable position indeed and
Kevin a quick thought from you on where
the labor player will position
themselves on this that I haven't yet
heard sort of criticism of the bank of
England coming from uh people in the on
the in the shadow treasury in the labor
party but where would they position
themselves considering the fact that you
know in 18 months time they actually
could be in power
yeah politically it suits labor to
attack uh the UK conservative government
uh Russia sunak the Prime Minister
Jeremy Hunt uh the the chancellor as
well as uh as Liz trust but they want
they want to pin it on the current
politicians that's why they think
they're not having it having a go at the
bank of England but there's no doubt the
bank of England has been slow there's a
big Splurge of uh inflation after Energy
prices went to the roof uh as did uh
food prices after the Putin invasion of
Ukraine you can't blame the UK concert
at the government for that but you can
come in complain and or critique its
handling of the crisis but no it suits
it suits a labor to go for the
politicians rather than the bank Okay
Kevin Annabelle appreciate that good
talk more from you guys later now still
to come we'll discuss more of the
stories making tomorrow's papers
including uh this one on the front of
the ftu about the former leader of
Italia Italy Silvio Berlusconi and State
funeral that was held today
[Music]
I'm Martha Kellner and I'm Sky's U.S
correspondent based here in Los Angeles
it's turning everybody into you know a
crazy violent drug addict
how are you feeling I am angry
[Music]
is an anti-woman agenda two women say
that you paid for their abortions are
you a hypocrite sir will your candidates
win I hope so but they will I think
they're great candidates
I gotta be realistic my sister's dead
more than four weeks old there's no
murder weapon and no suspect are you
going to catch this killer we are doing
everything we can
learn Maxwell has pleaded not guilty to
all six charges against her mum how are
you feeling today Jeffrey said you
answered together you just don't cross
her you're so excited severe nightmares
of these people coming in and just
taking me in the middle of the night
I've watched as whole towns were torn
apart by natural disaster I'm alive and
I'm thankful for that but there are a
lot of people who aren't it's not the
wins people fear most here it's the
water
we take you to the heart of the stories
which shape our world do you truly
believe what you're saying
cases that I know are reported from
Ukrainian missiles themselves Ambassador
with respect I think that's preposterous
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hello there and welcome back you're
watching the Press preview with me as
the associate editor of the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire and the deputy comment
editor the telegraph Annabelle Denim and
there they are guys it's cracked
straight on so I want to get to this
story uh that's on the front of the
guiding I'm sure it's in some of the
other papers as well
um Annabelle desperate Johnson hits out
at Tory MPS laid into sir Bernard Jenkin
why
yes uh so he is calling for uh the brex
support the brexit supporting uh
conservative Bradley soberna Jenkin to
uh resign this is following
um him allegedly attending an event to
mark his wife's 65th birthday at which
there were drinks and yes cake in
December 2022 when indoor socializing
was banned in London uh it's about a
Jenkins divide attending a drinks party
an ally has said that no rules were
broken this feels like Boris Johnson is
slightly clutching at straws I'm not
sure that there's been that much
widespread Sympathy for the idea that
this was a kangaroo court uh even if it
did at times feel as though it was
rigged against him the fundamental fact
uh remains that Boris Johnson has
resigned with immediate effect very few
sanctions will be able to be imposed on
him uh once the Privileges committee
report has been published with which is
obviously expected tomorrow I think this
just represents yet more Blue on Blue
attacks more mud slinging which has been
going on for years now it's been going
on
since the end of 2021 uh if not before
it became particularly bitter during the
conservative leadership contest last
summer and frankly I think the public
are tired of it and what we'll be really
telling is whether conservative MPS are
tired of it as well because there will
be a debate on Monday on whether to
accept the report's findings Downing
Street has decided not to whip the vote
um and Tory MPS are going to be free to
cast ballots against Boris Johnson after
and let's see what they decided they now
just desperate to draw a line under the
whole Saga yeah absolutely I mean Kevin
is it just blue and blue because What's
Happening Here is that Boris Johnson's
is once again attempting to undermine
the Integrity of this committee which
feels more than just mudslinging to me
yeah no no absolutely no he was toppled
as prime minister he he's Chuck his toys
out the pram and quit is an MP probably
jumped before he was pushed by this
committee and he he will he'll go he'll
go to his grave uh doing a baby Trump uh
with a temper tantrum saying uh it's uh
it's all against uh ends me the you know
the blob the committee uh has got it in
for me uh which of course is nonsense
when they've just looked at the uh the
evidence there's seven of them I
understand the report was agreed
unanimously it's a Tory majority for you
take off Bernard Jenkins and it wouldn't
make any difference anyway but he well
he doesn't grasp Johnson is the
committee isn't find him in uh in
contempt of Parliament and lying and uh
recklessly and misleading the House of
Commons because he
went to a party it's because he denied
he went to a party and lied had he went
to a party and he broke the rules that's
what it's all about so the comparison
with Berna Jenkins doesn't wash anyway
despite the fact Bernard and his T9 in
anything it is because Johnson denied
and lied to MPS in the house of Collins
that's why he is in such deep trouble uh
they still can't get it and he's been in
his head I think he's always created uh
he's his own reality his own false
reality he's he's fantasy it's but I
suppose it's what um some of trump
supporters would call alternative facts
that's why he's always grasping for and
the truth just gets lost okay uh final
thought Annabelle to you a different
story uh not related in the slightest um
Sylvia burners going on the front of the
uh Financial Times being laid to rest
and quite a turnout in Milan
yes that's right and it does seem that
uh he divided opinion in life and he has
divided opinion in death and it seemed
like a very fitting funeral for Sylvia
Berlusconi it was attended by his lovers
and an ex-wife his girlfriend 53 years
his Junior and I rather Like the quote
from the Archbishop of Milan who said
during his homily that Silvio Berlusconi
was certainly a figure who acquired
notoriety what a diplomatic uh statement
that was um but you know obviously he
was a towering presence in Italian life
for three decades one of the most
recognizable and notorious figures on
the international stage okay Annabelle
Kevin appreciate that both thank you
very much for your time this evening all
right let's take a look at what the
weather has in store for the next couple
of days
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the fine sunny weather continues
until the end of the week but the
weekend's going to bring a change as
heavy rain spreads in from the Atlantic
tomorrow morning early mist and low
Cloud Will Cliff to leave another fine
day with sunny spells it's going to
become warm Inland with temperatures in
the mid to late 20s Celsius Eastern
counters are going to be a little cooler
the afternoon will bring a few showers
mostly for whales and Ireland where once
again they may give way to some Thunder
downpours those showers will become more
widespread over Western Island through
the afternoon
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up on Sky News at 11 people in
Nottingham gather to remember the
victims of yesterday mornings attacks in
the city
[Applause]
foreign